c'est la polémique du jour ça concerne
une séquence diffusée hier dans
l'émission d'arte et 28 minutes alors
que l'écrivaine militante
rokhaya diallo étaient invités à
débattre avec le philosophe pascal
bruckner sur la place de l'homme blanc
dans la société
le débat a très rapidement tourné au
vinaigre le philosophe a porté des
accusations très graves sur rokhaya il
accuse entre autres d'avoir sa
responsabilité dans les attentats de
charlie hebdo et d'avoir je cite armes
et les bras des tueurs des propos qui
ont été évidemment ceci est qu'ils ont
ici c'est évidemment suscité des
milliers de réactions
le csa a même été voilà appelé avant
d'en parler je vous propose de revoir la
séquence était hier soir et rokhaya
diallo
elle sera avec nous c'est le truc qui a
fait le plus parler aujourd'hui ça a
énormément tourné sur les réseaux
regarder votre statut de femme musulmane
et noir vous rendre privilégiée ça vous
permet de dire un certain nombre de
choses qui si moi je les avais dit
notamment je pense à ce que vous avez
dit sur charlie hebdo écart entraîné
avec d'autres la mort des douze de
charlie ce que j'ai dit entraîné la mort
de quelqu'un oui ce que vous avez dit
que vous avez fait une pétition en 2010
à une pétition c'était un texte parce
que aucune metex a entraîné la mort de
quiconque ya très peu d'espoir que ce
soir si si et je l'avais désolé et c'est
scandaleux ce que vous dites est resté
quant à lui si je pense où les gens de
charlie hebdo mais c'est ce que vous
pensez mais vous n'avez pas à ma cause
est d'avoir entraîné la mort des deux
avait avec d'autres
cc à la haine c'est scandaleux charvet
devront user de ma liberté d'exprimer le
bras des tueurs je n'ai absolument
aucune responsabilité dans aucun à la
demande et aux gens d de charlie hebdo
de s'exprimer vous verrez ce qu'ils
pensent de vous alors est-ce que vous
avez été choqué par l'attaqué de cet
écrivain à rokhaya des russes a fait
énormément parler au kayak avec nous on
callas aujourd'hui c'est un des fers le
bon pour nous et dans l'est dans l'est
dans les médias sur les réseaux sociaux
quand comment vous avez pris le truc
comment vous sentez la la ça va mais je
dois vous avouer que j'étais estomaqué r
j'étais vraiment
je ne revenais pas de ce que j'entendais
je vous avoue que après notre échange
pendant la chronique suivante j'ai eu un
moment d'absence parce que je heureux
faisait l'histoire à me demander si
j'avais bien entendu les accusations qui
m'avait qui avaient été portées en ma
direction
c'est bouleversant fait c'est vraiment
je pense que c'est vrai que quand on
voit des gens débattre à la télévision
on oublie leur aspect une heure je veux
dire qu'une personne j'ai une famille
d'être à la télévision d'être accusé de
meurtre je tiens à dire que j'ai jamais
aucun de mes textes de mes propos n'a
incité à la violence de tic ce soit j'ai
donc de me retrouver face à une personne
qui m'a dit dean part que mes propos
avaient entraîné un attentat et que
j'avais était le bras armé de
terroristes c'est ces gens n'ayant
rappelé préalablement que tu es
musulmane
je trouve que c'est c'est extrêmement
brutal d'accor gilles je trouve ça d'une
violence incroyable
moi je soutiens totalement rokhaya parce
que sur un plateau télé on peut avoir
toutes les positions y compris polémique
qu'on veut mais lassé de l'accusation
la cde du discours diffamatoires c'est à
dire que ça accuse nominalement rokhaya
diallo
je trouve que c'est trop violent et je
trouve que franchement là pour le coup
le csa doit agir et moi si j'étais
rokhaya honnêtement je vous dis
j'attaquerai géraldine maillet alors je
trouve que l'époque est très compliqué -
elle est folle on peut plus parler
on est les uns contre les autres on est
dos à dos on et maya pas y'a pas de
dialogue
effectivement avec bruckner ya ya pas eu
de dialogue il est dans une mouvance des
moyennes pour moi après je trouve que
c'est compliqué aujourd'hui aussi
d'avoir un débat apaisé vont être tout
de suite renvoyé à sa race sa religion à
son ethnie et est ce que moi je suis
légitime par exemple pour parler de de
signe de l'islam ou de faire des
critiques par rapport à certaines
mouvances et en tant que non musulmanes
est-ce qu'on va pas me dire que je suis
raciste ou est-ce que je suis
islamophobe
enfin je trouve que c'est aujourd'hui un
dialogue de sourds qui est très
compliquée qui est très violent et j'ai
envie de citer juste une personne que
j'admire beaucoup en ce moment et qui
est très important c'est l'imam de
drancy hassen chalghoumi il dit on vous
demande pardon parce qu'il a été
beaucoup décrié un limon oui mais parce
qu'il a été décapité au no non mais il
n'est pas islamophobe quand même bien
non
demande pardon parce qu'il a été
décapité au nom de notre religion nous
disons l'attachement à la patrie
l'amour de ce pays parce que le discours
victimaire
c'est celui qui engendre la haine et qui
pousse certains à la vengeance
donc je voudrais avoir votre sentiment
moi ce que je ce que je déplore c'est
qu'on demande aux musulmans de témoigner
davantage de tristesse que le reste de
la population
vous imaginez bien que avec la période
convient traverse ce qui me semble
impératif de convoquer c'est le
rocaillement c'est le respect du deuil
et donc de désigner parmi les personnes
musulmanes qui est ou non responsable
c'est problématique
évidemment je suis outré par ce qui
s'est passé je ne pense pas que les
musulmans particulièrement doivent faire
preuve du fait qu'ils sont encore plus
outre avec les autres on est tous
français
ok on est tous français tous scandalisés
il ya beaucoup de gens qui a faim il ya
beaucoup de gens qui vous soutiennent
sur les réseaux ya aussi des gens qui
soutiennent pascal bruckner notamment
florian philippot rokhaya diallo toute
la mouvance indigéniste doit être
expulsé de la sphère médiatique
wei a pris ses aises depuis des années
cette mouvance est ultra louche dans ses
fréquentations raciste plein de haine et
ressentiment le terrain de la violence
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens il ya
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
qui disent que voilà qui qui vous qui
vous disent que vous êtes raciste que
vous faites du racisme anti blanc qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ces gens alors
moi je le savais je vous dis moi ce
convoi je me fais le relais de moi je
tiens à dire que je n'ai jamais été
condamné pour aucun de mes propos j'ai
jamais été attaqué pour les propos
soi-disant raciste que je tiens même je
n'ai jamais été attaqué pour ses propos
là florian philippot
ce que je constate c'est que il utilise
un drame pour faire de la politique moi
je ne fais pas de politique je suis une
personne qui a envie de penser la france
qui a envie de penser comment on peut
vivre ensemble tous c'était un débat qui
portait sur le féminisme en particulier
et pascal voeckler a décidé d'y glisser
une attaque qui n'avait rien à voir avec
le reste de débats j'invite les gens
d'ailleurs à regarder l'émission dans
son intégralité on parler d'autre chose
il habille ses choix pour me
disqualifier je crois plus rapide et pau
c'est un homme politique ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui vient pour essayer de
trouver un moyen de faire en sorte que
les français avancent ensemble on peut
être en désaccord je dire moi quand je
vais sur un débat sur un plateau c'est
parce que j'aurais dit non non des
accords sur plein de choses et
l'anonymat et se met aux personnes qui
sont là retravaillé chance que c'est
important de pouvoir confronter ses
idées et je le fais je sais très bien ce
que pense pas moi je vous dis
géraldine maillet je suis d'accord avec
elle sur rien mais c'est vrai mais c'est
mon âge et que la voir tous les jours
mais quand on était à tpm b avec
géraldine on a déjà exprimé des
désaccords et les unes avec les autres
mais on se respecte c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné
moi je vais m'excuser j'ai vite aux gens
moi je vais vous dire aussi moi je vous
dis il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit ah
tu travailles avec rokhaya diallo
rokhaya diallo c'est une raciste c'est
une antisémite comment tu peux
travailler avec elle fait du racisme
anti blanc qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ces gens mais de quoi ai-je été déjà
condamné c'est à dire que moi je ne veux
rien de trop ou et mais oublions les
défunts le terme de condamnation mais la
loi de la république c'est important
pour les enfants ont pu quand même dans
un pays de droit et je pense que la
liberté d'expression c'est quelque chose
de primordial
moi j'ai l'impression que les gens
aiment aussi isolé certains propos qui
sont tenus pour leur donner une chance
différentes
j'ai publié mon dixième dans la semaine
prochaine j'ai réalisé six documentaires
moi j'aimerais bien que les gens
prennent le temps de consulter mon
travail moi j'ai regardé votre travail
avant de vous engager également
et oui tout à fait et je veux dire qu'on
critique sur ce que j je l'entends mais
je trouve qu'il ya énormément de clichés
puis des gens qui aiment en fait créé
des ennemis de papier parce que en
réalité la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
quoi est ce que c'est de considérer de
dire que telle personne est responsable
de l'attentât
non puisque ça ne compte de trouver les
sources du terrorisme et de lutter
contre le terrorisme et se présente
comme un intellectuel créer un ennemi
papier est finalement possible moi alors
que je veux dire soyons sérieux je n'ai
aucun lien avec celle d'un terroriste
c'est vraiment de la posture c'est sa
volonté en ce moment et et moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup
après je n'ai pas de conseil à donner je
n'ai pas de leçon à donner
je suis personne et j'ai souvent dit des
conneries et j'ai souvent on fait des
conneries donc lieu pas de l'eau chaude
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je trouve
que beaucoup la mauvaise attitude
divisé en vraiment en essayant de mettre
les uns contre les autres en ce moment
de tout mais de mettre les communautés
les unes contre les autres les les
pensées les unes contre les autres on
est là aussi je vous dis en aidant suis
aussi dans une maison qu'on est dans une
chasse aux sorcières des musulmans ce
moment voilà on mélange tout et en ce
moment on est au lieu d'être tous soudés
et se dire on vit des moments très
difficiles avec la crise sanitaire avec
ce qui s'est passé avec ce professeur
qui nous a tous choqués ce week-end au
lieu d'être tous ensemble soudé contre
le terrorisme contre cette crise
sanitaire qu'on nous frappe c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment j'ai l'impression qu'on
est tous les uns contre les autres et
qu'on essaie justement d'attiser le feu
partout des cas une petite phrase n'est
qu'un petit mot d'écrire un truc
à prendre des proportions incroyables je
pense que vraiment il faudrait je le dit
prêt je n'ai pas de conseils à donner
je suis personne et personne à personne
voilà personne ne doit à m'écouter mais
si j'ai un message à faire passer je
pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on arrive à
tous être soudé parce que la cia une
dérive incroyable en ce moment et je
peux vous dire que là le monde est en
train de partir en cacahuète et la
france en ce moment fait peur à tout le
monde on va en parler dans un instant
dans balances ton post bien entendu mais
c'est vrai que là c'est encore un
exemple et la met les uns les
incontrôlée de se mettre les uns contre
les autres c'est pas du tout la bonne
solution ayant naples en plus qu'ils le
font à des fins politiques
et c'est inadmissible